[Music]
anybody know who jack dorsey is yeah
yeah yeah twitter twitter
designed yeah you did
he has anybody heard of this
there's a new indian ceo right oh cool
they're taking over isn't the ceo of
apple i mean apple uh alphabet
indian as well yeah honestly people the
indian people in general are like
running the tech space yeah how do you
go from call center to ceo i don't
understand that they work hard that's
their ladder it's just one step to the
next
it's cab driver call center
and then ceo
i think it's engineer and then ceo
yeah they're good at multitasking yeah i
think they're really good at that i mean
ultimately uh but i love the way that
jack did it obviously uh he did it via
twitter
he actually posted his resignation
letter as a as a tweet because you know
he felt that twitter needed to be a
transparent company has anybody read
this letter no but i kind of saw it come
in during um all right so do you
remember the time when
all of social media was under attack by
the government
um they were the government was trying
to take over all the bit like fake like
trying to regulate it right yeah so
facebook was under investigation during
that time um so big tech
was having to comply a [ __ ] ton with the
government meaning like the government
was basically putting zuckerberg on
trial and um other guys like dorsey and
saying like
if you you know the reason why trump got
elected and because of russia or that is
because you guys weren't controlling
your [ __ ]
and so if you don't control your [ __ ]
we're gonna come in and take it cause
you can't you're not responsible with
what you're doing and then that's why
also social media got so um
control heavy right like you make a
wrong post the bots get you all this
[ __ ] right it's because they're like
they're overreacting so then the
government can't say
you guys are [ __ ] up so we're coming
over and we're taking over right
also during this time now jack dorsey
used to be all about freedom of speech
he used to be this guy that was
pretty crazy like twitter still to this
day you can have porn nudity you can
have cam girls go there and [ __ ] show
their ass all day long you can show
[ __ ] whatever right
but what's weird and what are these
accounts that i need to follow now yes
you just look at uh
who's uh adding you and then they'll pop
up
the truth is so funny
so so the thing is though
on twitter
i i felt like that was the place where
you could say whatever you want do
whatever
but they started
canceling
accounts that weren't that wasn't
fitting the narrative of
silicon valley and also their beliefs
maybe more left maybe whatever right so
all these like republican accounts
started getting
basically silenced and taken out or
whatever
and it was weird and then so
it yeah during that whole time when they
all silenced trump and all this stuff
and you know i'm not right or left i'm
just saying that the series of events of
what happened it was kind of weird
big tech when they silenced trump they
also silenced a lot of other people
and and and you know i was like this is
weird it just seems like there's some
kind of cooperation going on here
and
and and they're choosing one political
side when they're supposed to be more
like hey you could say whatever it's an
open forum instagram's like that too
they shadow band people yeah like you're
like oh i'll see someone post someone
else's thing and i'm like clicking them
oh wait what did that person say again
and then if i missed the post i'm like
okay let me just go in the search and
search for that account and i'll type in
exactly what that person's name is and
i'm like what the [ __ ] can't find it
yeah i can't find it yeah
it's weird it is weird yeah yeah
but then during that time jack dorsey
was being dr uh basically drilled about
this stuff
by um
republican congressman i think it's ted
cruz the texas dude but he was there's
interviews during the pandemic of him
pressing him and saying you know if this
is an open forum how come twitter is
deliberately banning banning these
people like
different media outlets or whatever that
doesn't fit
the
left ideology and they're like if it's a
fair platform why is this happening and
then he was like oh i don't know i don't
know
and then
it didn't seem like this
the same jack dorsey that came into the
space where he was like yeah you could
say whatever you want whatever whatever
and then like it sounded way more like
rehearsed speech
if you want free speech i think you got
to put a comedian in charge
that's true make dave chappelle see you
or something oh my god imagine that yeah
then you can enforce free speech
damn from
from like a ceo perspective like um
like jack josh is obviously he's
stepping down he's put into you know
another ceo in his place and stuff like
that um he believes that you know the
true intentions and the beginnings of
twitter are also still going to be
carried on you know and that's like why
he's still trying to even like put post
his res resignation via twitter to make
things transparent because twitter is
supposed to be like a very very
transparent and growing kind of like
company corporation and stuff like that
like how does and maybe i'm just asking
to ask like how does a person who like
helps co-found something like that
what do you feel like stepping down as a
ceo like what what do they have to offer
by doing that like what he's like i'm
tired of this [ __ ]
that's what he said sounds like he's got
beaten down over the years he's like i
can't do this [ __ ] no more that's what
it sounds like all the crypto meme pages
i follow they're like he's about to
double down on crypto
huge bitcoin supporter he's very bullish
on it but like
do you think he's resigning out of
like um
either wear and tear or like are people
like actually being like force
resignation that's my theory that's why
i brought up the whole the government um
and how he was coerced to
choose a side they're saying that
there's there's maybe something else
something thicker in the water
because it doesn't make sense to me that
all of all the big tech companies all
social media simultaneously at the same
time decided
to coordinate the silencing of trump and
several other members in media and
accounts
but it was mainly
what was weird to me is
the president
standing president
was being completely silenced by all
these different platforms at the same
time like
why did they coordinate that
that's just my question it's like it
makes sense if youtube bans them and
goes no more youtube
and then like or facebook goes yeah you
can't talk on facebook but
they didn't let them have any access to
social media at the same time not just
trump too like the
hydroquinone that was like a
you don't talk about that what
hydrochloroquine for those of you that
are paying attention yeah like what that
was like how he said when that was a new
like option
across the board you post about it done
yeah and then ivermectin you post about
it done across the board it's just
there's so many synchronized things
which is crazy
there's a new one too uh it's a
supplement called
n
nac i think that's the abbreviation or
something so it's a it's a yes the
success meme
there's a government um study that was
done on it and and how effective it is
against uh kovid it's it's a gov site by
the way right scientific journal
everything and inside of it there's a
report conclusion is it's highly
effective uh against uh kovid a lot of
patients that took this it's a
supplement it's an over-the-counter
supplement you could buy it on [ __ ]
amazon right
and then
it's the off amazon and now you can't
get it over the counter you have to get
it
through a prescription and it's a
[ __ ] supplement dude yeah that's so
crazy yeah and it's what because it's
effective with kovid that
i think it's big pharma moves you know
it's like if anything is cheap effective
with kovid it's it's they can't profit
off of it they're going to take it off
because they want to be the ones that
have a monopoly on selling pills to us
but what you know what's crazy the
craziest story i heard
is so you know ivor mexicans highly
uh prescribed right over four billion
uses across the world really yeah and uh
one of our buddies that's in taiwan
uh just so that he can have his own
covet protocol he bought it through one
of his doctors but now in taiwan if a
doctor prescribes that they get thrown
in jail and then whoever if you go hey
doctor um my cousin took this i also
want to take it then you also get thrown
in jail in taiwan
no way
god that's crazy yeah yeah my money is
money is killing like you know like cuba
they allegedly have a cure for lung
cancer
they do yeah and so when they when um
when our former supreme leader
made roads with cuba
one of the things they were negotiated
was to give us the this alleged cure so
trump was trying to negotiate a deal to
give us the it wasn't just seriously for
that i think that was one of the
parameters in it um trump was trying to
cure lung cancer yeah i think trump just
wanted uh cigars but uh that's just my
opinion uh
so the doctors here were like well you
know their statement was very skeptical
we gotta see and so my my cynical side
was like they want to see what they can
implement so they could put their
fingertips in it so or fingerprints in
it so they would they can make money
yeah i'm charging because if it's if
it's free for everyone and all the
doctors can do it how are they going to
make money no but if they put their
fingerprints in it then they can say oh
well we've made it better yeah so we're
now we're going to charge xml yeah it's
our product the patent of it yeah like
my conspiracy theory is when you look at
food the nutritional like what's inside
and there's stuff that we can't
pronounce we don't know what it is that
this is what i think it's like if i if i
have a cracker and then joe has the
patent for ribo nucleo blah blah blah
blah whatever and he's hey dude um can
you do me a favor put it in your cracker
and then i'll give you x amount of
dollars like what does it do it does
nothing it doesn't taste like anything
but we'll just put it in there so i'll
buy it and then he'll give me a kickback
and that's what that's my conspiracy
theory on why things have so many
ingredients if you look at pills
someone's gonna have a patent for some
chemical like hey just throw that in
there bro come on just do me a favor
like i'll give you like a couple million
dollars yeah and then like why wouldn't
you do that like you you sure that
nothing's gonna harm me oh it'll be fine
it'll be fine don't worry about it and
that's how
these white people i mean are wealthy
people
they stay wealthy because they're always
piggybacking off each other and they
just you know that's how they do it
you know that is the game and you know
what socks is
like like traditional media won't
won't they won't talk about this right
alternative media which is gaining in
hella [ __ ] numbers by the way like
joe rogan and you know small channels
like us like we can openly talk about
this without consequences like
mainstream media
they're funded by pfizer they're funded
by [ __ ] moderna they can't say
anything that might hurt
their
you know so pfizer maduro
oh my god that's what i'm in it for not
the money i'm advisor in this
hey [ __ ] delicious that's what i'm
trying to say is we won't be talking so
much if you just sponsored us yeah dude
everything's money like radio stations
are money you know american companies
pay the radio station to play their
music i don't know if they do it as much
anymore because of streaming but like
mary j blige the big thing with her her
first song was real love this is back
when video jukebox is around you guys
remember that you call in you pay a
dollar to play video they spent ten
thousand dollars
um the record label did and they just
put it on video jupiter so whenever you
turn it on real love was always playing
so our impression was that wow all these
people are ordering it
but the song was good it just happened
to be a good song but we thought people
everyone was like doing that but no no
no one was buying it no one was getting
it a thing it was a record label yeah so
money is involved when you watch a news
segment and they're doing a thing about
an athlete and they athlete eats
potatoes during her meal yeah that
segment is will be sponsored by the
potato grenades yeah like a potato group
like a coalition of yeah yeah like the
milk companies yeah they've got milk the
milk sponsorships all that yeah they'll
do all that and so i think definitely
money is the bottom line
difficult to believe anything that's
like on on spotify i have a friend whose
wife works at spotify and she said that
um there's a department where all the
dudes who are the curators for like
hip-hop or like rap caviar you know all
those like playlists that you see great
playlist yeah he said that she said that
they just every day they got tons of
gifts on their desk from like people
that are like hey get my song on that
playlist get my song that playlist every
day
i got a gift for him too bro i got a
mixed step coming up your boy
you